I mean my life for the last year has
been so busy that I haven't had proper
time to reflect on what's been happening
and even if I did I wouldn't I'm not
exactly sure I would be able to
understand it anyways because it isn't
sure I'm not I don't think I have a
framework of a reference within which to
put it so I started working for this
company called television TV Ontario
about 1516 years ago I talked to a
producer his name was what at Schamberg
he's a immigrated Polish Jew and a
really smart guy and he phoned me up at
the University and one of the things
that distinguishes me to some degree
from my colleagues is that I'll talk to
the press and that I'm actually not
afraid of them or distrustful of them
like a lot of my colleagues not all of
them are like they're critical of the
press partly in an arrogant way and
partly in a defensive way they say well
they always get it wrong it's like well
first of all there isn't that they and
they don't always get it wrong and you
know they'll also shy away from the
press as if they're being intruded upon
when the truth is generally speaking the
ideas that they're putting forward
aren't of sufficient interest in draw
public attention anyways and so but I
talked to would act for a long time and
he invited me to go on a couple of shows
and then then I ended up on TV owes the
agenda which is a pretty good public
affairs show it's one of the few I would
say deep news shows left that that are
on normal broadcast TV and you know they
go into issues in some depth although
they've fragmented that up a bit in
recent years and I became a fairly
common guest on those shows and people
seem to like what I was saying which
always surprised me I mean but but it
was good because you know it must be
pretty damn horrible to put yourself out
in the public eye and face primary
criticism for what you're doing I think
that would be unbearable in some sense
unless you were very very strongly
constituted and then well that went on
for a while and modak was running this
series called big ideas which was
actually quite prescient you know
lecturers come to Toronto and and he had
all pretty much all the major public
intellectuals in the world over a period
of about five years or six years or so
come and deliver bare-bones lectures of
this sort fundamentally and he'd taped
them and put them on TV you know and and
that was sort of unheard of the
production quality was well high but not
over produced there weren't multiple
cameras and edits and an intelligent
commentary from people in the background
it was purely content driven you know
and it actually got pretty popular on on
iTunes and you can still find the
lectures there but TVO couldn't they
they they pulled the show even though
their primary mandate from the
government was to educate the public and
this was a very low-budget show with
very high quality minds that people were
actually watching and downloading a lot
on iTunes but they they didn't seem to
take the non-standard media with any
degree of seriousness and you know
that's kind of a common human attribute
which is that if you don't know about
something you don't take it seriously
right and it's because if you don't know
about it well it's just gray and fuzzy
right to you you have no differentiated
knowledge so it's easy to oversimplify
it